work very hard enjoy what you are doing
I think it's essential when you have a
literary vocation to fill that writing
practicing this this vocation you are
receiving the most important rewards for
what you are doing and I think if you
work with this kind of feeling it is
much more possible that what you'll
write will be good literature that you
will succeed as a as a as a writer that
if you write in a mechanical way yes if
you were practicing any other kind of
work or job I I think writing or
composing or painting is also a job of
course but it's a very special kind of
job in which practicing the job you are
already receiving a fantastic kind of
reward for what you do you are doing
something in which you are realizing
yourself accomplishing yourself
something that was a very important
necessity of your own personality in
order to be how can I say lawyer'
lawyer' with yourself that would be my
advice to a young writer enjoy what you
do be very serious self critic of
yourself and
and receive this kind of compliment that
is to be satisfied with what you are
doing you know